the jurogan experience
you do real boots on the ground
investigative journalism you are a
[ __ ] gangster woman
the [ __ ] that you did in peru and in
colombia i was watching that episode on
cocaine
my hands were sweating watching you do
this it's like
you were you went to the places where
they're growing it
to the places where they make it
yeah that was you marched with the
people that carry it
through the route when they're carrying
it in their backpacks
yeah i was like oh my god like you're
risking your life like
genuinely risking your life i don't like
to see it that way you know no story is
worth
a life so i hate i hate you know we
minimize the risk but you know there's
these are important stories to tell
these black markets are happening all
around us
they're super widespread i think we have
this idea that they're happening in sort
of faraway lands and deep and secret
locations but they're not
and they have a real impact on our lives
so there is a reason
why we do the kind of reporting and
you're right you know boots on the
grounds
old school journalism i think is more
important now than ever
and we are seeing less of it nowadays
it's so hard to do i mean to find
someone willing to do what you did for
that cocaine episode i watched it last
night i was
i was sweating i was like nervous i was
riveted
it's it's such a it's such a
dangerous but yet it's so
much more illuminating than any other
kind of journalism you could say
oh this is happening in colombia oh this
is happening in peru
and i'll just sit at home going oh i
guess that's happening in colombia
but to see you who i know there
going there and to see all the stuff
that you had to go through
to meet with these people and to gain
their trust
yeah i would say also i would add to
that that
you know we did mexico with fentanyl we
did guns here in the u.s going to mexico
we did tigers in asia and all these
different scams in jamaica and israel
and i think a big important
reason or goal for us with this show uh
and
for me in particular because it's the
way that i approached my job and
my career as a journalist is to not
only be there to inform of what's
happening like you were saying
but also i think it's important for
people to connect to people in these
faraway lands that
at first glance we have nothing in
common right these are
the bad guys operating in far distant
lands or maybe sometimes around us but
they're considered the bad people
uh the people that we have nothing in
common with but if you actually sit down
with them and listen to their stories
and this is the big shocker of this show
and i think it rubs people a lot wrong
way sometimes when you admit
or or when somebody tells you that
look actually there is not a lot that
differentiates you
from the guy smuggling cocaine out of
the peru the frame valley in peru
you both have the same are motivated by
the same goals which is you know
happiness
uh an opportunity in life a chance
for you know to reach your dreams um and
unless you actually look at it this way
and start realizing that that is more
often than not the case
of course there's a lot of bad people
there doing it for greed and solely
greed that also happens and i spent a
lot of time with those people as well
but unless you start understanding sort
of the root causes of what leads people
into these lives
you're never going to be able to address
black markets
well you really did a fantastic job of
getting close to these people
and talking to them like you know they
were talking about their family they
were talking about their children
um the one guy who is the chemist who
wants to get out because he wants to go
to school and like this is my last year
yeah it's it's it's horrible that story
alone we spent the night with these
mochileros these backpackers teenagers
who carry the
loads of cocaine on their back out of
the valley and spending time with them
and
you know really dangerous work they tell
us stories about how they hike for
days on end out of the amazon the frame
valley
um to a place where then it's sent out
into
outside of the country to europe and to
the united states and you spend time
with these guys and you listen to them
and
and it's incredibly dangerous work too
they've seen their best friends being
killed in front of them
and i asked them so why would you ever
want to do something like this you know
and he's like look very simple i grew up
in a very poor family
i always wanted to go to college i knew
that
the only job opportunities the whole
economy is essentially sustained by the
growing of coca leaves
production of cocaine and smuggling of
cocaine so the only job opportunity here
i had
was this and i asked him well why do you
want to go to college so badly perhaps a
stupid question
but he said you know because i want to
be a dentist i said why a dentist
because i want to meet
make people smile and this just is like
these are the moments that i think will
really
stay with me and it was so genuine
like the experience was so raw like all
of it from
showing the families growing the coca
leaves and
i learned something from it i always
assumed that it was the organized crime
cartels that were growing the coca
leaves
but no it's these families these very
poor families that are growing these
cochlears
and drying them out by the road
where everyone can see so you have
children
playing you have these very poor
people that are growing this this crop
and the vast majority of it is sold
to the cartels and they they're not
selling it for a lot of money either
no not at all it's never the people at
the bottom that are making money it's
always the people at the top
but it's crazy that these are the people
that are growing it yeah like
this whole valley has been growing coca
for thousands of years it's what they do
and it's also crazy that the thing
itself the coca leaf
like there's actually been people that
have made a really good argument that
not only should that stuff be legal
but it's probably good for you yeah the
coca leaf a lot if
alone if it is not made into cocaine
it's
uh if you they chew it you know you go
to the andes and all around they
actually chew the coca leaf i had an
opportunity to do that there was a
moment where
one of them i mean you do it it helps
you without high altitude sickness
and it helps you gain more energy and uh
when we were filming with a group they
actually wanted me to try some i had
tried some before but i did it as well
then
and uh and it tastes it's actually it
doesn't taste it's it kind of tastes
like a leaf
quite frankly uh but you do feel a
little bit more
energy and there's nothing there's
nothing illegal about that by the way
that's
completely something that's been doing
they've been it's been the tradition in
this area for
you know thousands of years mm-hmm and
when you did it like what gave you
energy like what did it feel like
it's not like a bump of cocaine have you
done a bumble bee i actually have not
you know it's so funny
i spent my entire life reporting on
drugs and drug the drug trade
and i am and i'm you know people you
know
like do crazy [ __ ] for a living uh and
yet i am terrified of drugs i think
partly because i've seen how they're
done
well after the oxycontin express and
seeing how many people's lives are
destroyed
by a legal drug uh i could
i could imagine why you would want to
avoid the ones that are illegal i've
never done coke either that's what i'm
asking oh you haven't no
never no i think we're some of the only
two people
i took tea once mate dakota tea
have you ever had that made with
coca-cola yeah and i couldn't shut the
[ __ ] up
which is the problem already that's a
problem with me too that's exactly my
problem
is that i am high energy all the time if
i were to do cocaine then i don't think
anyone could
exactly exactly i my friend jimmy in
high school when we were
when we were young uh one of his buddies
was uh
was selling coke and uh and he go he
just looked at me goes you should never
do this stuff
i go why it goes because i think you'd
love it and i'm like okay
that's probably my problem too i'm
afraid that i'm gonna i think everybody
loves it
i think it makes you feel amazing i mean
there's got to be a reason why it's so
popular
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience